les rangs le deal notre ennemi ça c'est
la grosse question
l'iran n'est résolument pas l'ennemi de
personne en tant que pays en tant que
peuple le peuple iranien est l'ami de
tout le monde c'est le peuple plus
paisible le plus pacificateur qui a
jamais existé
il suffit de regarder son histoire
l'iran n'a jamais été un pays
envahisseurs
l'iran n'a jamais été un pays guerrier
il y a quand même une petite période
afghane là où il y a quand même notre
show off shore
il a envahi l'afghanistan c'est vrai
mais ça ne constitue pas une grande
caractéristique la grande
caractéristique delà de ce pays en
revanche la république islamique est
l'ennemi de son peuple
à mon avis parce que l'intérêt des
iraniens ne rentre pas en ligne de
compte de ses dirigeants et je trouve
que la république islamique pourrait
s'avérer extrêmement dangereux aussi
bien pour la france pour les communions
européen que pour toute la région
la région du moyen-orient de la france
était depuis 40 ans le grande la grande
alliée de l'iran la plupart des
présidents de la république en france
ont soutenu les orientaux nord même
quand la dernier épisode dans le dernier
épisode que qui viennent de passer les
manifestants étaient armés de leurs
smartphones 1500 morts du côté des
manifestants
aucun mort du côté des agents du régime
pourtant ça n'a pas empêché les
dirigeants de la communauté européenne
de condamner ou plutôt de reprocher la
violence de deux côtés donc vous voyez
il n'y a pas de
risque que la relation entre la
république islamique et l'union
européenne et surtout pas me la france
n'y a aucun risque que cette relation
dégénère
[Musique]